simply hit me it didn't mark up to our
expectations number one we sought legal
opinion on the matter we had hoped to
have uh the final legal opinion by the
end of this week uh we felt that
government perhaps had rushed it a weep
at the in relation bringing this forward
uh there's a choreographer there
following sethovich and James clevery's
meeting on Friday but legally the
opinions we got back were quite clear
that it wasn't as a platitude of words
it certainly wasn't any way legally
binding and we felt that particularly uh
disappointed by by government's decision
to go forward today do you think that
you were misled them about the strength
of it that we talk about the storm will
break well I thought I always try to be
careful with my words I think the the
Prime Minister was certainly over
enthusiastic when we when he was in the
Coca-Cola factory we wondered how he
don't call the cook because he was
obviously bouncing from foot to foot he
was in a high uh that right away put us
on a regard because we fully
refrigerated herself I mean it can't be
that's good well that certainly wasn't
that wasn't even good at all so it's
rather disappointing that we find
ourselves in this position where we have
a very very large Divergence of opinion
between the conservative party and
ourselves in relation to legally the
storm would break is nothing more than a
handbrake it's not a stop it's a
handbrake it's a story The handbrake is
better than nothing though isn't it and
also it's something that many people
have said you want me to do at all well
I have to say sorry I thought that the
handbrake would stay on and then I would
say to myself that's that we have
something to work on today
the Secretary of State and Horace give
us his opinion his opinion was uh that
that 30 mlas from two different parties
two different groups can uh can ask for
any a new EU legislation to be stopped
now with that when you look at that
initially you say well that's good but
then we found out it's it's conditional
first of all it goes I'm not quite sure
what it meant to be just going to the
community then it comes to Westminister
so what we need to have is a legally
binding document written written in in
the laws of Westminster that we have in
the screen behind us in a way that we
know then we have we can depend upon the
30 mlas to actually do something but
here's a here's the problem the problem
is it goes to Westminster goes to the
government whoever the minister is in
charge and prime minister uh they're
naming a decision whether or not to to
support and and back the 30 mlas the
legal opinion that we get tells us that
it's nothing more than words so I'm
sorry uh to say that that we're not
convinced and by the way there's better
illegal Minds than me I'm just Jim Sean
I'm not a legal mind but but people are
I never advisors the ARG had their legal
opinion separate opinion uh they were in
order back home and and some of the
loyalist groups had their illegal
opinion a different legal opinion but
all those legal opinions came the same
conclusion it's not legally training it
doesn't work what would you say to
people who might be listening to you and
thinking look
the cat's out of the bag the dep are
never gonna back anything when it comes
to a brexit deal in the EU you're always
going to hold out you're always going to
find a problem and you're never going to
accept it
uh I I would say that we've been trying
to find a problem look we we're we
believe in Devolution we want to see
Devolution being successful we would
love to have a um an agreement before us
at at Westminster that that gives us an
Avenue and a way forward from the very
beginning we have had discussions with
the prime minister with James cleverley
with the the Secretary of State and
other members of the of the uh
conservative party to try and find a
constructive way forward we have
intermitted to the conservative party
that there are a number of outstanding
issues which have not been addressed now
there are things some of the green knee
and stuff is positive but the negatives
are that that the veterinary medicines
hasn't sorted the issue of of calc
nibbons to to Sterling and and to to
Barrick are not sorted the issue of
fishing uh um issues not one of them has
been sorted the Constitutional position
has not been sorted uh the EO the the
European Court of has not been sorted so
we we've asked for things to be done the
unfortunate thing is we've asked for
weeks and they haven't seemed to have
tried at all the other thing that hasn't
been sorted is the government in
Northern Ireland yeah still not still
not up and running what is the dep's
position are you now prepared to
re-enter government uh I I think that
today's voters uh uh as clearly put our
position uh on record uh um we do not
see at this time that we can engage in
in the unassembly once again that we've
asked what's going to happen is it just
gonna I mean this is a huge issue for
people in Northern Ireland they haven't
got a functioning government a cost of
living crisis what are you going to
re-enter well I mean we we fought an
election uh last year we received a
mandate uh and the Monday it was clear
that the
protocol issue had to be sorted uh the
winter framework was put forward in in a
an overall energetic fashion by the
Prime Minister making it and that'll
think of perhaps it had been sort of the
fact this is not so from our point of
view uh we will continue to engage uh
with I think some of the conservative
MPS today even I think the Secretary of
State to be fair uh had then debated
that the discussions will will be
ongoing so our point of view are still
to be heard now some people would say
look this is just excuses you don't want
to get into government you don't want to
see a champagne first minister no no I'm
afraid that that's not the issue uh as
far as we're concerned as a party we
accept the Democratic mandate we accept
that the Shen Fein are they are the
largest party in the first Minister we
we can't that's a democratic I'm a
Democrat I believe in that I believe
that wholeheartedly so that's not the
issue the issue is you and I say not to
you personally but the government must
sort the issues that we have put forward
to them they must give us some guarantee
on the Constitutional position of not
we've asked for that I asked for that to
and I'll tell you who the MPS and who
the ministers were today who asked me
what do we need I says we need something
on the Constitutional position of
Northern we're undermined we're weak uh
I want to be as pretty as what you are
therefore you have to do that so I I
understand lose requests to the
ministers and prominent ministers as
well uh will be
um brought to the attention of the prime
minister at their next uh meeting of of
the uh government so we we do live in
the hope uh but until that time comes
okay we I don't believe we can we can
move forward and construct the fashion
I'm sorry to say now while I've got you
um I just have a bit of a change of time
because we've been talking an awful lot
about uh brexit we're talking about
covid talking about tax returns and I
just want to talk about this motion here
which I have to you've you've tabled a
parliamentary motion right and this is
to recognize the 50th anniversary of
Dolly Parton's I will always love you
there she is and I have to admit I am I
I I'm a fan I love the fact that I heard
book kids book scheme which you can
access in the UK it's extraordinary if
you haven't heard of it it's every month
any child under five can get a free book
thanks to this lady it's extraordinary
yeah tonight in Parliament my uh labor
colleague and friend Ruth Cadbury uh
mentioned to me about that very books
I don't know about it by the way uh but
but Dolly Parton uh what a voice uh what
a what a character uh she's an Ulster
Scott by the way so I I think I think
her ancestry probably comes from the
same direction
um but I think as a person that I just
whatever song she sings It's brilliant
uh and and for me and for my wife as
well uh we um we love her uh we love her
music uh and um I think when she sings
wow I just stopped to listen you know
um I I think in the Hustler bustle of
life as well and I I think it don't make
me sound I think the early day motion
today resonated with so many MPS check
it tomorrow morning you'll see many
piece of signed it I've had so many
Lydia said Jamal I just love that EDM I
signed it right away you know so
tomorrow morning there'll be lots and
lots of MPS who will have signed it
because they love Dolly Parton as well
some of them some of them have had their
hands in there they says Jim love Dolly
Parton Isis not as much as me